Look at these babies.
Oops, sorry.
That was probably, NSFW.
Hey there handymen and women, this is DNews,
I'm Trace.
January 30, 1787, Thomas Jefferson wrote a
letter to James Madison, saying "I hold it
that a little rebellion now and then is a
good thing, and as necessary in the political
world as storms in the physical."
But by "rebellion," I don't think he meant
that candidates should "debate" by making
fun someone's hands, and by extension, their
sex organs.
But even still, is there ANY correlation between
the male penis, and OTHER parts of the body?
Firstly, no.
Nope.
No.
None.
A study in the journal BJU International literally
looked at and systematically reviewed tens
of thousands of male members to finally deflate
any debate about our sizes.
This any other studies have found average
penis sizes had no strong correlation with
testicular size, weight, or whatever.
There is very shaky evidence linking digit
ratio of the second and fourth finger to hormonal
exposure in the womb, which may correlate
with penile proportions.
The study was published in the Asian Journal
of Andrology in 2013.
So, yes, this one small study of Korean men
says the ratio between two of your fingers
might be important…
Julian and Julia covered it here, but scientists
are skeptical.
But, you know what they say about men with
big feet though, right?
Big shoes.
And that's about all you can infer in this
context.
A study by London's St. Mary's Hospital and
University College Hospital of 104 men found
no correlation between their shoe size and
their penis size.
So look, there's not really any strong, irrefutable,
repeated scientific evidence that visible
body parts, relate in any way to penis size.
The average, by the way, is 3.6 inches (9.6cm)
flaccid and 5.2 inches erect (13.1cm).
If that seems small to you, assess why you
think so, and if the answer is the sex theater
of pornography, stop.
The human male has the largest penis of any
primate in the animal kingdom, and only 5
in 100 men have an erect penis over 6.3 inches
(16cm).
And after all that, if you're worried about
penis size, welcome to the club.
Only a third of men surveyed were satisfied
with theirs according to a 2013 Journal of
Sexual Medicine paper.
The researchers said most men surveyed had
issues with their height, weight and penis
size; their feelings on the matter were heavily
tied to self-esteem.
In fact, the researchers found no matter the
size, some people just bratwurst braggarts
even those with a teeny weenie.
Finally, women surveyed in a paper in Proceedings
of the National Academy of Sciences in 2013
found size is just one little factor in a
huge array of measures of attractiveness.
Big dongs were related to attractiveness,
but small ones didn't hurt, the ladies honestly
just didn't care about it that much.
As Science Magazine wrote, "To really reap
the benefits of a big penis, a guy needs to
be attractive in the first place."
Also attractiveness aside, does the size of
pretty much ANYTHING under your clothes make
you a good or bad leader?
We are watching people vying for the most
powerful office in the U.S. verbally measuring,
fat-shaming, and comparing hairstyles.
They're concentrating on appearance, and people
aren't laughing at them but with them.
But even still, they're not alone, appearance
is something politicians worry about… for
example, why don't campaigning dudes have
beards anymore?